how do I start a makeup line I got a
question from one of my Twitter
followers Naomi who wrote in the say
Evan how do you even find the laboratory
to start a makeup line do you have to
pay them to help you how does it all
work Naomi so Naomi okay unless you have
money burning a hole in your pocket or a
ton of cash in your bank account going
to the lab is not going to be your best
play here at the beginning because yes
you do have to pay them okay understand
the business that these makeup labs are
in they want to produce high quantity
products right they don't want to deal
with you who might be ordering a
thousand or a hundred or a demo product
but they don't want to work with you
they want to look the companies who are
going to order millions of units from
them
so that's the type of customer that
you're you're working with you that's is
this is your supplier how I would get
started if I were you okay number one
pick one thing don't think about a whole
makeup line pick one thing that you want
to get good at if you look at the
successful makeup companies and how they
got started if you go way back they had
one product that they started with
became known for made some money with
and then expanded to everything else so
whatever you're most passionate about if
it's lipstick or Rouge or blush or
eyeliner whatever it is pick one thing
that you want to focus on and just do
that to start and you can worry about
the line down the road okay that's the
first thing number two get started try
doing something on your own if you go
back and look at how these companies got
started it was usually the founder in
their kitchen mixing up some recipes and
making a product learn about whatever
one product you're getting into so if
you're doing lipstick know everything
about lipstick know what goes into
making a lipstick try to make your own
from your kitchen just get started and
don't wait on some manufacturer to make
it for you and number three is model
success go out and learn from people who
are doing this and it comes in two ways
the first is learn from the companies
who've come before you so look at Revlon
look at Estee Lauder
look at how they got started not how
they sell now but how dit had it estee
lauder go from an idea to making a first
million dollars learn from that success
and apply it to your business go work
for a makeup company go work at one of
these companies that are making this
stuff so you can learn about the
business ideally you find the company
that has 10 20 employees
small app that you can get some real
responsibility and you're going to get
paid to make mistakes you're going to
get paid to learn the business you're
going to be paid to make connections so
when you're ready to launch you have
experience you know who to talk to you
you have a much greater chance of
achieving success that's how I would do
it and I wish you the best of luck
believe those your watching like video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think or if you have a
question leave in the comment section
below I make a video reply and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you want to see more videos like this
thank you guys so much and I'll see you
soon